bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors depuis quelques
semaines c'est la même question qui
revient les talibans vont ils prendre le
contrôle de kaboul et quand personne ne
pouvait se prononcer précisément mais là
avec toutes les grandes villes qui
tombent entre les mains des insurgés la
prise de kaboul est ce que finalement ce
n'est plus qu'une question de temps
tout à fait moi je crois que le fond civ
des des talibans visent clairement la
capitale et vise bien évidemment le fait
d'avoir ou d'un kata qu'apparaît le
pouvoir du du pays il a maintenant on
est en train de deux pays les des
erreurs de l'otan des états unis de tout
le laxisme on va dire à occidentales
face à ceux à ce qui s'est passé dans ce
pays donc ce qui fait que la maintenant
l'état nippon profitent de cette
situation de d'instabilité et profite
également de la situation de l'armée
afghane l'armée officielle c'est à dire
que on est face à une évolution de
l'armement des talibans qui était basé
seulement sur des stratégies de guérilla
face à une nouvelle stratégie c'est à
dire une armée officielle face à une
armée d des talibans prenant en
considération que par exemple les armées
officielles de l'afghanistan en compte
trois cent mille soldats alors que les
talibans c'est seulement soixante quinze
mille soldats mais ils ont les moyens
ils ont cumulé également l'expérience de
faire des guerres qu'ils eux et qui leur
permettent en fait content d'avoir une
percée intéressante dans dans ce pays
mais il faut pas seulement se limiter
sur
l'objectif on va dire des talibans ou
par rapport au pouvoir mais il faut voir
aussi la situation de l'afghanistan d'un
point de vue géopolitique parce qu'il ya
énormément de pays qui s'intéressent à
l'afghanistan comme étant un
point stratégique pour la géopolitique
dans l'asie centrale alors vous le
disiez à une armée régulière qui
manifestement on pose une faible
résistance aux talibans pour quelle
raison précisément l'armée afghane ne
fait pas le poids face aux talibans
je crois en principalement là d'accord
la corruption parce que il faut savoir
quand même que l'armée argon ces faits
parmi les armées les plus corrompus dans
le monde selon même les rapports
américains les etats-unis sans dépenser
2000 milliards de dollars en matière de
formation et et d'armement là maintenant
on parle aussi qu'il ya des fuites
d'armement et d'information de l'armée
afghans vers l'est vers l'ailé les
talibans de même on n'a pas construit on
va dire une architecture claire de du
pays par rapport aux accords de doha
c'est à dire la question de la nouvelle
constitution le conseil de
réconciliation nationale le fait de
créer un gouvernement d'union d'union
nationale ce qui ouvre la porte pour les
talibans de profiter de cette situation
d'instabilité mais j'aimerais bien aussi
signalé que les liens étroits et
historique contre eux le talibans et le
pakistan sont aussi très très fort et un
pacte clairement la situation
actuellement un afghanistan donc c'est
pour ça que j'étais la géopolitique il
est très importante je crois qu'on est
face à une nouvelle alliance qui émerge
entre
pakistan afghanistan iran est également
la chine la chine qui maintenant on veut
marquer cette situation comme étant un
nouveau acteur est clairement intéressé
1 par les matières premières de
l'afghanistan par le fait de faire des
liens de transport entre l'afghanistan
l'iran et
le pakistan
ce qui permet à la chine d'avoir un
point de force par rapport à oudon dans
le cadre de cette rivalité avec les
côtes chinoises alors aujourd'hui tout
le monde en s'accordent à dire que
l'armée afghane n'est pas de taille
qu'elle ne peut pas seul combattre les
talibans quel peut-être alors la
solution envisagée si ce n'est les
regarder en puissant l'aghanistan tomber
moi je crois pas qu'il y aura une
intervention occidentale là dessus les
américains ont décidé clairement de
faire un retrait stratégique de ceux de
ce pays même si que le retrait et les et
les malfaiteurs ouvrent la porte ou
talibans de profiter de cette situation
je crois pas que le temps va répéter la
même à la même erreur de 2002 2001 mais
ce qui peut se passer c'est à dire c'est
qu'il faut pas attendre à que les
talibans détient le pouvoir à kaboul et
après il y aura une négociation
politique de manière à faire une
intégration politique ou de créer un
gouvernement d'union d'union nationale
mais il n'y a pas plus que ça en tout
cas l'union européenne a prévenu un haut
qu'un gouvernement contrôlé par les
talibans ne sera reconnue l'afghanistan
sera ainsi isolés on sait que c'est la
population qui va en pâtir est ce que
c'est vraiment viable disent orléans si
l'afghanistan
je crois que c'est très difficile du
fait que l'afghanistan a des liens avec
son voisinage c'est à dire l'iran le
pakistan la turquie aussi parce que la
turquie la manne en détient l'aéroport
de kaboul avec 500 soldats
les relations aussi avec avec avec la
chine mais je crois ce qui intéresse
l'union européenne actuellement c'est le
danger de la crise des réfugiés c'est à
dire qu'on est vraiment face à une
nouvelle crise d'immigration qui se
profile à l'horizon suite à ces drames
humanitaires en afghanistan et qui
peuvent impacter les autres pays de
l'asie centrale c'est-à-dire
l'ouzbékistan le tadjikistan et les
autres et les autres pays de cette de
cette région younes belle fait la merci
à vous d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes consultant en
relations internationales et spécialiste
du monde arabe merci